안녕하세요, 여러분 모두 환영합니다. 오늘 다들 어떠신가요? 이번 수업은
정말 멋진 듣기 말하기 수업이 될 겁니다. 여러분 모두 여기 와주셔서 정말 기쁩니다. 모두
환영합니다. 화면 보이시죠? 네. 좋습니다. 자, 기억하세요, 좋은
의사소통은 좋은 경청에서 시작됩니다. 적극적인 경청자가 된다는 것은 여러분이 몰입하고 있다는 것을
보여주는 것을 의미합니다. 때때로 우리는 요점을 파악하기 위해 빨리 듣는데, 그것이 우리의
빠르고 직관적인 사고방식이고, 다른 때에는 신중하고 분석적인
경청이 필요합니다. 그때가 바로 우리가 사물을 정말로 세세하게 분석하고
그것들의 더 깊은 의미를 이해하려고 노력할 때입니다. 그래서 우리는 두 가지 유형의 경청을 모두 연습해야 합니다.
사물의 피상적인 수준의 의미를 이해하고,
사물의 더 깊은 분석적인 수준을 이해하기 위해서요. 연습을 많이 하면,
요령을 터득하게 되고, 그것을 이해하기 위해 일부러 그렇게까지
애쓸 필요가 없어집니다. 그냥 이해하게 되고 시간이 지나면서 더 직관적이 될 것입니다. 하지만
먼저 분석하는 것은 항상 좋습니다. 자, 여기 시나리오를 읽을 테니 잘 들어보세요.
다른 초점을 두고 두 번 들려드릴 텐데, 제가 여러분이 이해하지 못할 수도 있는
무언가를 보여드리려고 합니다. 그러니 이해하지 못하더라도 너무 속상해하지 마세요. 알겠죠?
네. 좋습니다, 팀원 여러분. 새 프로젝트를 위해, 모두 화요일 업무 종료 시까지
결과물이 시너지 효과를 낼 수 있도록 협력하고 통합해주시기 바랍니다. 선제적인 이해관계자 참여를 보장해주시고요.
신속하게 처리해주세요. 이해하셨나요? 요점은 알겠지만, 새로운 단어들이 좀 있네요.
다른 것들은 괜찮습니다. 네, 어느 정도 경험이 있으시군요, 좋습니다. 우리가 무언가를 끝내기 위해
함께 일해야 한다는 요점은 파악하셨지만, 여기에는 여러분이 이해하지 못하는
몇 가지 사항이 있을 수 있습니다. 어떤 단어들이 이해하기 어려우신가요?
제가 이해하지 못하는 단어들은
'synergize'와 'snappy'입니다. 네, 무언가를 'synergize'한다는 것은 기본적으로 서로 협력하여 더 큰 효과를 내도록 하는 것입니다, 그렇죠?
요소들이 함께 작용하여 시너지 효과를 내면, 그것들은 'synergized'된 것입니다. 그것들은
함께 잘 작동합니다, 그렇죠? 그래서 우리는 기본적으로 모든 사람이 함께 모여
화요일까지 어떤 결과물, 즉 무엇이 생산되어야 하는지에 대해 동의하고, 'make it snappy'는
그것을 빨리 하라는 뜻입니다. 아, 그렇군요. 말씀하실 때
그 단어를 사용하시는군요, 그렇죠? 아, 'make it snappy'(빨리 해).
네. 그럼 짧은 시나리오를 듣고 여러분이 이 회의에 있다고 상상해보세요.
회의에서 그런 말을 듣는다면, 이해하기 위해
어떻게 말을 끊고 이해하려고 노력하시겠어요? 만약 어떤 질문이 있다면, 요점은 파악하셨죠?
하지만 아마도 다음에 나올 말을 좀 더 듣고 싶으실 겁니다.
어떻게 설명을 요청하시겠어요?
음, 선생님께서 말씀하신 것처럼, 모든 것은 경청에 관한 것이죠. 그래서 저는 그 사람이 말을
마칠 때까지 기다릴 것 같아요. 그리고 만약 이해하지 못하면, 그때 가서
"실례지만, 방금 말씀하신 이 부분에 대해 설명이 필요합니다."라고 할 것 같습니다.
그러니까 상대방이 하고 싶은 말을 다 끝낼 때까지 기다리시겠다는 거군요. 그건
누군가가 말하고 있을 때 무례하게 굴거나 방해하고 싶지 않기 때문이시죠. 네. 사실, 저는 항상
기다리려고 노력해요. 왜냐하면 상대방이 무슨 생각을 하는지 알아야 하고,
단지 그렇게 말씀하신 것만으로 이해해서는 안 되니까요. 네, 추측하지 않는 것이 좋습니다. 동의합니다. 그리고
말이나 대화 중에 잠시 멈추는 순간을 기다렸다가 설명을 요청할 수 있다는 것을 아는 것이 좋습니다.
네. 그럼 어떻게 정중하게 말을 끊을 수 있을까요? 그것이 오늘 우리가 이야기하는 내용의 일부입니다.
명확성을 요청하는 것. 유용한 표현들이 있습니다. 음, 저는 "실례합니다,"
라고 말할 것 같아요. 그게 좋은 예시가 될 것 같네요.
그래서 저는 "실례합니다만, 이 계약에 대해 말씀하실 때 무엇을 의미하시는지 알고 싶습니다."
와 같이 말할 것 같아요. 네. 그래서 이 주제들에 대해 더 많은 설명이 필요합니다.
알겠습니다. 매우 정중하시네요. 마음에 듭니다.
네, 저희는... 그게 저희가 회의할 때 대화하는 환경과 같아요.
밖에서는 농담을 할 수 있지만, 회의 중일 때는
정말로 전문가처럼 행동하려고 노력해야 합니다. 회의 밖에서는 더 편하게 행동할 수 있지만, 회의
자체에서는 전문가답고 격식을 갖춰야 할 때입니다. 네. 그래서 이 말의 격식은 정말로
다소 격식 있고, 억양도 중요합니다. 아시다시피, 억양은 높아졌다가 낮아지기도 하죠. 그래서
예를 들면, "죄송합니다. COB에 관한 부분을 다시 한번 말씀해주시겠어요?" 또는 "make it snappy에 관한 부분을
다시 말씀해주시겠어요? 그게 무슨 뜻인가요?" 와 같이요. 네. 이제 여기서 'could'를 사용했다는 점에 주목하세요. 'could'는
'can'보다 더 정중한 표현으로 간주됩니다. 그래서 'could'는 조금 더 격식 있고, 'can'은 조금
더 편한 표현이지만, 둘 다 사용할 수 있습니다. 누군가가 'can'을 사용한다고 해서 무례한 것은 아니지만,
더 격식을 차리고 싶다면 'could'를 사용하는 것이 좋습니다. 여기 또 다른 예시가 있습니다.
이번에는 끝부분에서 억양을 높여보도록 하세요. "Is that right?"(그게 맞나요?)처럼요.
네. "Is that right?"(그게 맞나요?) 여기 이 부분을 읽어주시겠어요?
제가 제대로 이해했다면, 저희에게 요청하시는 것은... 그게 맞나요?
그게 맞나요? 네. 그리고 여기 또 다른 예시가 있습니다. 저희가 일을 많이 하고 있죠. 그게 맞나요?
이번 주말에 출근해야 한다고요. 그게 맞나요? 네. 이건 어떠세요? 이 부분을
읽어주시겠어요? "snappy"가 무슨 뜻인지 설명해주시겠어요?
네. 아주 좋습니다. 안녕하세요, 'snappy'요. 음, 'snappy'는 빠르고 재치 있다는 뜻입니다.
음, 아니요, 괜찮을 것 같아요. 예를 들어, 선생님께서 말씀하신 COB처럼 사용할 수 있습니다. 왜냐하면
COB가 무슨 뜻인지 모르는 사람들도 있으니까요. 그냥 간단하게 "snappy가 무슨 뜻인지 알려주시겠어요?
저는 이걸 몰라요. 저에게는 새로운 단어예요."라고 말할 수 있습니다.
아시다시피, 때때로 우리는 무언가를 모를 때 당황스러워하는 것 같아요.
그래서 묻고 싶지 않고, 인정하고 싶지 않지만, 명확히 하는 것은 괜찮습니다.
의사소통과 비즈니스의 전체 목적은 이해하고 이해받는 것입니다.
그리고 이 슬라이드의 핵심 내용은 기본적으로 정중한 요청을 할 때 'could'를 사용한다는 것입니다.
"Excuse me"나 "If I understand correctly, you're asking..." 또는 "you're telling us that's right"와 같은 대화 연결 표현을
사용하고, 그들이 말한 것을 다시 한번 말하는 것입니다. 그것들은 정말 훌륭한 방법입니다.
설명을 요청하는 데 있어서요. 네. 그럼 계속하세요, 죄송합니다.
아니요, 예전에는 그렇게 하지 않았을지도 모르지만, 지금은 단어의 의미를 묻거나
그들이 무슨 말을 하는지 알기 위해 질문하는 데 더 자신감을 느껴요. 그래서 그들이 정확히 무엇을 전달하려고 하는지
알 수 있죠. 네... 시간이 지나면서 더 나아질 뿐입니다.